this is elise she lives and works in los
angeles but she's originally from
australia hello because of kovid she
hasn't been able to visit her home
country in over two years
she's visiting new york this weekend and
while she's here we decided we'd try to
cheer her up
i don't know where to take her she's
australian right yeah take it out back
steakhouse
[Music]
you know this isn't real australian food
right yeah but they have fun australian
puns on the menu okay
and it's free i'm in welcome to new york
what do you know about outback um i know
that outback uh i think originated in
america yes true and has
australian inspired cuisine
i guess we'll find that part out you'll
you'll tell us if it's inspired
wow
this is the famous blooming i've heard
of these before
this one looks wild what is this
deep-fried mushrooms okay
we would call that prawns okay and these
chips and those we'd call mushies
actually
okay this is what i'm most excited about
oh it has a little thing on the top how
do you cheer in australia you just say
cheers cheers
cute cheers she is she is
oh my god that's great i really like
that a lot
it's got um cinnamon notes i can down
this maybe i'm just thirsty but i think
i am
wait did she say that this little thing
on top is edible yeah oh okay i will say
though
this is a little bit more fried than
what you'd typically find on an
australian okay if that's fried i think
that's uh just coconut shrimp that's
fried do you think these grew out of the
pond i do actually the the coconut
shrimp tree i think we can just start
yeah let's eat
[Music]
oh that's so good
okay i love that
the like spice mix on the batter it
reminds me of curly fries
yeah one thing i miss about australia is
like we have ads totally different from
the ones you see in america like we
actually have ads for mushrooms
we have a mushroom jingle oh my god do
you want to sing it oh why don't i just
say that okay it's like um mushrooms the
great old round uh
because you can put mushrooms without
even anything i can't wait to like look
all this up and find out you made all of
yourself you've never been to australia
she's actually been putting on the
accent the whole time
okay am i
doing the honors
i like it
i mean how can you not like this it's
not it's just fried eggs
that's kind of like the star of the show
i think yeah and i'm actually impressed
that it actually pulled a pot
so i've heard that this is the most
caloric item on any
menu ever
i wonder if that's true oh my god really
but i feel like it has a lot to do with
the size of it yeah yeah i feel like
this is a sharing plate although
you never know
what is the general attitude about
kangaroos are they pests are they
friends are they pets are they everyone
loves kangaroos um
and emus are respected because of the
emo wars oh yeah they tried to eradicate
them and it didn't work
do you know about this no i don't
actually so they were like an invasive
species and the government brought
machine guns to try to kill them and the
emus won
because they attacked the people with
the guns no they they they won so far as
they didn't like they only killed like
three emus that's crazy main course time
great looks great why do australians say
how you going instead of how are you
doing i like that more yeah how are you
going how are you doing because it
suggests that there's always uh progress
yeah
there's more to be done there is more to
be done i suppose okay should we try
this
yeah
okay this is way better really good yeah
that is actually
such a good steak really well seasoned
yeah juicy perfectly cooked
i think i'm guessing this is called a
cers is it as well in australia yeah yes
i wonder if you guys coined it maybe so
cheers to this lobster though oh yeah do
you guys want to dip it in the oh
absolutely i do it's butter oh my god
okay
thank you
that's a vehicle for butter it's it's
perfect you can never go wrong no i
guess i'm realizing now i don't really
like love style
is new zealand the canada of australia
yes yeah 100 we're all friendly we all
get along but there's a little bit of
like a friendly rivalry of like you know
like kiwis
this looks like something you would get
when you're a kid at the tuck shop what
does tuck mean yeah i guess in australia
you would say tucker is food so tuck
shop is the food shop can you use tucker
in a sentence um guys come over tucker's
ready should we just chop into it i
think so i think just go for it yeah i'm
just gonna like do it yeah do a stab
so far this is 100 the most australian
thing here i've seen okay yeah
[Music]
i just want to like carve down i think
we have to let's just go for it oh my
god
[Music]
that's pretty amazing you can't go wrong
with that no that's pretty solid all
right alicia's has a surprise for you
i miss my friends my family but most of
all i miss the food i miss hot jam
donuts uh that's something that i grew
up eating after a netball game from the
hot jam doughnut truck for a dollar
fifty unlike a
jelly doughnut is a little bit more
fluffy it's coated with caster sugar
instead of powdered sugar and the jam is
piping hot in the middle it's just an
iconic australian tree okay oh my god is
that a hot jam no no yeah no way sort of
so did you dust off a jelly doughnut and
put caster sugar i could not find caster
sugar in america okay so i took
granulated sugar and i put it in the
food processor okay and this is a
raspberry jelly donut and i microwaved
it so it's a little hotter okay it
should be piping hot on the inside it's
hot it might be cooling as we speak okay
shall we describe how it's the same or
different yeah i really appreciate the
effort first of all thank you um but the
hole in a hot jam doughnut is going to
be on the top oh no
yeah wait
and usually yeah when you get it it's
like you know like oozing out the front
like that is it hot in the middle it's
not lava if i did that to a hot jam
doughnut my finger would be burnt oh no
but hey
it's the thought that counts and i
am touched
so does all this make you feel more at
home
um it does make me feel more at home
my home america
i feel we shall do it
yeah
thank you thank you guys for coming
um the most vicious creature in
australia is called a drop bear they
fall out of the trees and they'll knock
you out and they like actually prey on
people passing by like do they fight
they're like they're like they're like
heavy and knock you out way
they're evil koalas imagine what a koala
is but they're an evil koala and they'll
fall out of the tree and pounce on you
and i love that are they trying to eat
you why is everything in australia
trying to kill you
no nothing is trying to kill you except
for droppers
they don't have thanks but they like
will attack you with their body and
their claws oh my god that makes me want
to go even worse yeah
i want to be dropped
boom